in october 1993 shortly after beavis and  butthead premiered on mtv a  five-year-old ohio boy got a hold of a  lighter and set his bed on fire the  blaze quickly spread through his  family's mobile home he and his mother  escaped but his two-year-old sister did  not the blame for the tragedy was  immediately placed on beavers and  butthead and their love of fire  [Music]  let's burn something  local fire chief harold ziegler stated  when you take a child in the formative  years and you get these cartoon  characters saying it's fun to play with  fire this is going to stick in that  kid's mind as a result mtv ultimately  removed all references to fire from past  and future episodes of the show for the  duration of the original run turns out  it was all a mistake fifteen years later  the accidental arsonist publicly stated  that he'd never even seen the show since  the family didn't even have cable at the  time